brought to you by Dark Souls 3 pre-order
now to receive a free upgrade to the day
one edition hello once again friends I'm
Lucy and welcome to in two minutes so
last week I went over the dark and
gloomy law of Dark Souls in preparation
for uncovering the secrets of the
upcoming Dark Souls 3 just so you know
this episode's bonfire was lit by our
friends at From Software so according to
game directors series creator and now
studio president head otaku Miyazaki
Dark Souls 3 isn't going to be the last
Souls game in the series but rather the
turning point and while we're not
entirely sure what that means 3
definitely seems to take bits and pieces
from the other Souls games let's take a
look at what's new in Dark Souls 3 souls
games are something of a time investment
so there's always the risk of getting
bored of your character well Miyazaki
has confirmed that you'll be able to
respec your undead pals starts mid game
so you can get that perfect build but
bored of your move set well with the
touch of a button you can access new
options with the battle art system each
weapon has a couple of set alternate
stabbing options simply tap the button
and enter into a ready stance which
gives you fancy new moves to play around
with these are powerful attacks so
they're limited to 20 users before you
have to refresh them at a bonfire see
can't just spam the crap out of them but
it does make the game a little more
flexible especially when your backs up
against the wall magic is changing a
little bit - or at least it's returning
to how it used to be way back in Demon
Souls magic in Dark Souls 1 and 2 was
limited to a set number of charges but
now it's gonna be a traditional mana bar
which you can top up using a new kind of
Estus flask called an ash Estus flask
this means you can get more magic for
your buck as spells consume different
amounts of mana and offer charged up
variations while yes they do take up
more mana they also deliver way more
damage from all the gameplay we've seen
so far yep there's gonna be some
disgustingly huge creatures to take care
of each boss encounter
be an unpredictable affair bringing out
new weapons and moves throughout the
fight to keep you on your toes
and finally Humanity is gonna work a
little differently
this time around it Dark Souls 1 if you
die you become hollow hollow state means
you can't summon phantoms into your game
or invade others to fix this you need to
consume a humanity which restores your
HP and grants you discovery bonuses and
a bunch of resistances but in Dark Souls
3 instead you consume an ember and
commence Lord of cinder mode it
basically allows you to become a
multiplayer house so you can summon
other players to your side but you also
get the sweet delicious benefit of a 40%
HP bonus and your armor glows to warn
enemies that you're coming to look
fabulous I'm not sure there's a reason
so there we have it all the stuff to
look forward to in the upcoming Dark
Souls 3 now all that's left to do is
prepare to die